hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
book one of saint augustine's
confessions begins with augustine
confessing that he's a bit confused
about the nature and we might say the
location
of god where can god fit in
what can fit into god where could
god be and this is
particularly pressing given that in the
very first chapter we have one of the
most famous expressions of augustine
and in in philosophy in general
he tells us that our heart
is restless until it rests
in you lord and so what does it mean to
rest in god is this something merely
metaphorical well we have to figure out
where god can be and
what god can be in order to have any
possibility
of answering this and if we back up just
a little bit in this very first chapter
of book one he tells
uh god as because he's talking to to god
man this part of your creation wishes to
praise you you arouse the human being to
take joy in praising you for you have
made us for yourself and our heart is
restless until it rests in you and he
says lord grant me to know
and to understand
which is first to call upon you or to
praise you and also which is first to
know you or to call upon you
you know there's sort of an ordering
question
going on there
calling upon knowing understanding and
augustine is going to attempt to try to
understand and you know part of this is
figuring out is
is god in me do i rest in god how does
god get inside of the thing that i
am and he's going to mix these all up
together
in the next several chapters but i think
we can do well by parsing them out and
looking at them
one at a time different
ways in which we might know or
understand
god and nowhere understand where god is
so we can think first about
god and the created universe so the
totality
of what is and augustine brings up
heaven
and earth first he talks about that and
then he talks about
hell
um so he says
here we go
how can god come into me god who made
heaven and earth right so this is much
greater lord my god is there anything in
me that can contain you in truth can
heaven and earth which you have made and
which you have made me can those
actually
contain you
or because without you whatever is would
not be does it hold that whatever exists
contains you so you know we've got a
couple different things
going on we've got this notion of god
heaven and earth and indeed everything
that that is right implarae is the latin
infinitive for that there's actually a
line uh where god says implano right i i
fill
heaven and earth and then the question
is do these things contain
or grasp if we want to take an even more
literal translation of the capri here do
those things contain god because god
fills them and this is a genuine
question
that
augustine is considering here something
that we do need to keep in mind
he goes on and he says
do heaven
and hell
contain you since you fill them or do
you fill them
and
does there yet remain something further
since they do not contain
you
and part of what's going on here is
augustine is working through some
commonsensical but mistaken
understandings of what's actually going
on here
can god be
parceled out so that we'd have you know
the part of god that's in heaven and
earth and then a surplus
or
because of the thing that god is the
kind of thing that god is not a thing
actually
is this a mistaken way of looking at
things and he he goes on a little bit
further
and says
where do you defuse what remains of you
after heaven and hell have been filled
or do you who contain all things now
notice that
this is a reversal of perspective
it's it's not that first you've got
heaven and earth and then god fills them
up after maybe god makes them or
something like that
god is greater than heaven earth hell
all these things put together
and god contains them rather than them
truly containing
god and he says um
you fill
all the things you fill by containing
them the vessels that are filled by you
do not restrict you even if they're
shattered
you are not poured forth
right you fill all things and you fill
them with your entire self but since all
things cannot contain you in your
entirety do they then
contain a part of you a bit of god like
god's a bit over here and a bit over
here and a bit over here some god's up
in heaven some god is in earth some
god's down in hell and in all the
different things that are that are in
those and he says no that's
that's not going to work do all things
simultaneously contain the same part do
single things contain single parts
greater things containing greater parts
smaller things containing smaller parts
and
he's bringing this up because this is a
wrong-headed point of view but he's not
actually going to come straight out and
say that so god can't really be parceled
out as if like you could have you know
well three quarters of god existing here
and then the other quarter
over there
in chapter four he turns to talking
about
what we can say about god
we talk about these as the
divine attributes in part but he says a
lot more than just the traditional
divine attributes
and maybe this is a way of thinking
about
where god is god is in these
attributes
he says what then is god
um
what i ask unless the lord god who is
lord but the lord who is god but our god
now that's kind of vacuous that doesn't
tell you an awful lot and so he launches
into a whole bunch of mosts most high
most good most mighty most almighty most
merciful most just most hidden most
present most beautiful most strong
stable and incomprehensible unchangeable
yet changing all things now notice that
we are getting some what appeared to be
opposites here some paradoxes
most just and yet most merciful
uh do these actually go together this is
you know something that people had to
think about quite a bit
and a lot of that continued on after
augustine unchangeable yet changing all
things never new never old yet renewing
all things
most hidden
most present there's a lot of
paradoxicality to this i'm not going to
go into every single
epithet that he has here but we should
think about some of these
there's there's a long segment where he
talks about all the different things
that god is doing
with
the created beings
he says
gathering in yet needing nothing
supporting
fulfilling and protecting things
creating nourishing and perfecting them
searching them out although nothing is
lacking
in god there's no there's no
you know other thing motivating god to
do all these great things it's just what
god does and then he said here we get to
the really paradoxical ones you love but
are not inflamed with passion you are
jealous yet free from care you repent
but do not sorrow you grow angry but
remain tranquil you change your works
but do not change your plan you take
back what you find though you never lost
it
you are never in want but you rejoice in
gain you are never covetous yet you
exact usury and and we could go on and
he says what have we said my god my holy
delight
what does any person say when they speak
of you right
we try to grasp god
in all of these
things that we can say about god these
ways we can conceptualize understand god
is that where god is
now we get to talking about the human
being
himself
and we have a real quandary here
how can god enter into
a human being
he says when i call upon god i call up i
call him into myself
what place is there in me where god can
come i mean i'm a finite creature i'm a
little thing i'm not heaven and earth
i'm just one tiny little thing in earth
right now maybe i'll be in heaven maybe
i'll be in hell you know later on
how is god going to come inside
of me
and he says
this is a real problem because i would
not even exist i wouldn't be unless god
was
in me and then we see again this this
reversal or rather i would not be unless
i was in
god unless i
was in you from whom by whom and in whom
are
all things
and he says to what place do i call you
since i'm
in you this is this is a very
interesting way to think about it right
if
god is in everything and god contains
everything
and i'm one of those things in that
everything
how am i going to get god in me
is god already in me in a trivial way
well that's not particularly helpful
what do i need to do
and here we see something
that is going to be characteristic of
augustine's thought in general and and
you could say
christian thought in general
he says
who will give me help so that i can rest
in you who will help me so that you will
come into my heart
and inebriate it to the end that i may
forget my evils and embrace you my one
good how can i get god inside of me the
part of me that matters the most
how is this going to
work
and he says
he identifies a problem too narrow
is the house of my soul for you to enter
into it
so
that could be the end of the
discussion right
too narrow no god in here
well what do you do that
so he
calls upon
god to help him out
let it be enlarged by you if my soul is
too narrow
open it up
help me out here and give me what i'm
lacking
my soul lies in ruins
build it up again
make it something that can actually
take in god
he says i confess and i know that my
soul or my heart contains things that
offends god's eyes
who will cleanse it or upon what other
than you shall i call from my secret
sins cleanse me o lord and from those of
others spear your
servant so he's saying
all right i can't buy my
own capacities my own talents or even
other people that i call upon
help myself out in this respect and get
god in me
god's got to do the work god has to
enlarge my soul god has to
build it back up from ruins god has to
cleanse it so that it's a suitable
place you could say a suitable resting
place for god so that augustine himself
can
rest in god so all of these you know
sort of seemingly
metaphysical speculations about well
where's god
they have a very important
purpose and this is why
perhaps augustine
begins the confessions
with asking these questions without
completely
answering them at that point in the work
you